[Music]
word had arrived in mexico city almost a
year before
the japanese were coming
hundreds of them led by a noble
ambassador from the great emperor their
sovereign lord
a great galleon of 500 tons was being
prepared
the news had set off a friction of
excited chatter and expectation in the
capital of new spain what had once been
the great aztec city of tenochtitlan
and now
they were here
the native nahuatl lord chimalpahin
gaped in awestruck fascination as the
procession wound across the roads that
poked their heads above the great watery
expanse of lake texcoco to enter
mexico city
as the visitors got closer he could see
that the first men marching held black
lances straight up before them like
roman lichters
then came the ambassador himself in a
coach and finally a great mass of others
bringing up the rear leading hundreds of
heavily laden pack animals
they are long-haired their hair reaches
their neck from letting it grow long
they look like girls because of the way
they wear their hair
they wear something like an ornamented
jacket doublet or long blouse which they
tie at the middle their waist where they
place a katana an asian cutlass of metal
they seem bold not gentle and meek
people going about
like eagles
the japanese ambassador in the carriage
looked straight ahead gazing opaquely
into middle distance
as if the sights of this strange city
meant little to his world-weary soul
the tension was palpable all mexico city
had turned out to greet the embassy but
as with all great occasions there was
ample room for mistakes to be made
indeed aside from the mission's leaders
the japanese had already been forced to
surrender their weapons in acapulco the
primitive seasonal west coast port which
traded with asia after an unfortunate
disagreement over who should present the
diplomatic gifts they brought
this event culminating in a brief battle
several severe wounds and one fatality
jamal
suspected that the badly injured
spaniard viscayno had double-crossed the
japanese just as the spanish had
double-crossed his own people a century
before to claim the great prize of
mexico itself
he wondered if the spanish had designs
on the japanese islands he thought it
likely their appetite for others lands
was insatiable but it was hard to
conceive of them sending a force strong
enough to such remote parts
and he had heard that the population of
japan was immense with boys and even
girls taught to kill from childhood
it was said that they were even happy to
turn their sharp blades on themselves to
atone for wrongs
the procession continued to the very
center of the city the embassy was to be
housed in comfort and honor on the way
to its ultimate destination
rome
cimalpahin felt this great embassy
marked a new era
all powerful god in his great wisdom had
allowed the spanish to conquer mexico
and drive out the devilry and idol
worship that had held the aztec people
in subjugation
jamal pahin or to go by his christened
name domingo francisco de san anton
munyon chimal pahin was himself a
faithful servant to this new deus
and now the word of jesus could be
spread even further across the great
ocean to japan to drive out distant
idolatry
he lowered his head and gave a silent
prayer of thanks before crossing himself
god
was coming
[Music]
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question what was the largest empire in
the world at the time of hasakura
suninaga's globe trotting adventure was
it a ming china b the iberian union or c
the dutch
yes the answer is the iberian union i
think the huge combination of portugal
and spain that broke up in 1640 and so
my recommendation this week for
magellan's exhaustive collection is
magnificent three cities that shaped
history it's a fascinating 400-year-long
epic that tracks the centers of three
important empires amsterdam london and
new york an epic tale and an epic series
that explains the foundations of the
modern world and magellan have more than
3 000 other documentaries to check out
too and this christmas voices of the
past viewers can take advantage of a
special holiday offer buy one get one
free gift cards for an annual membership
by clicking on the link in the
description
thanks
[Music]
the japanese lord ambassador hasakura
suninaga sitting upright and stiff in
his coach
attempted to stretch his legs without
the crowds outside seeing
he had been traveling for five months
already first through the accursed
desert of salt water they call the ocean
then through the interminable dusty
mountainous roads of new spain
now he'd arrived in mexico city
glorious unquestionably but still
nowhere near his ultimate destination
of rome
asakura was there to redeem his family
name from the disgrace his father had
wrought through fraudulent dealings and
subsequent
seppuku short years ago hasakura had
watched him passively as his father
kneeling and dressed in a ritual white
kimono had pierced his own belly with a
tanto knife before a kaishaku second had
spared him more agony by swiping off his
head
lord date masamune the arbiter of all
justice and hasakura's liege lord had
simply nodded
and left
later hasakura himself had been summoned
to his lord's presence but instead of
receiving the same sentence as he had
expected he was given orders which were
perhaps nearly as bad as death itself
lord date ordered him to journey around
the world to the lair of the catholics
rome to talk with the man they called
their holy father the pope an attempt to
get his support for opening the pacific
ocean trade routes between asia and
north america and if the price of that
was hosting more catholic missionaries
than so be it
hasakura's mission would take many years
and the chances of returning were slim
he had fought with distinction in korea
in his youth but this mission was
something else
but it was his only chance to redeem his
family name
what was more lord daate had briefed him
on the shogun's suspicion that the
spanish had designs on japan
suninaga was not only an ambassador
but a spy
and so with this weight on his shoulders
hasakura stared straight ahead as his
carriage rumbled on
but he could not stop his eyes being
drawn to this new city as it unfolded
around him it wasn't rome but it was
like nothing he had seen before
one approached a shallow lake on raised
promontories before being encircled with
ingenious man-made islands on which
stood a hodgepodge of houses and markets
docks and warehouses passing onto the
main island wide promenades revealed
themselves tall houses churches mounted
with great crosses and palaces of stone
and brick with carved facades surrounded
them nothing like the wooden one-storied
buildings of japan
and what a diverse range of peoples
natives of these lands black-skinned
people spaniards and even some men who
clearly look japanese though they could
be korean or chinese
the coach which he had ridden in the
last few leagues drew up he alighted
stiffly and entered the edifice
they were in mexico city for several
months following orders hasakura
permitted his men to be baptized much to
the delight of the local people it was
the diplomatic thing to do and it also
made a lot of sense to placate the local
gods when traveling far from home
the japanese kami clearly had little
power here
he himself declined despite the council
of priests who warned him of the dangers
of the journey ahead and urged him to
look to the safety of his immortal soul
he was steadfast in his refusal
for hasakura had more weighty matters on
his mind than the rescue of his soul
already condemned to disgrace by his
earthly lord
he wanted the drama of being baptized in
the presence of king philip iii of spain
this act alone would go a long way
towards redeeming his family name and
establish the glory of his lord date
masamune in europe to a japanese warrior
of the time these two things were far
more precious than a mere token shot at
the unproven but promising christian
afterlife
baptism could wait a little
they proceeded to seville the only port
permitted to accept ships and people
from outside europe having left the
jurisdiction of the viceroy of new spain
they had taken up their weapons again
and hasakura and his men proudly entered
the city dressed as samurai with swords
in their sashes bows and spears held
high in ceremony
[Music]
after a whole year of travel they had at
last reached europe only the second
embassy in japanese history to land upon
the continent
they all breathed a huge sigh of relief
their journey's end could not be much
further surely
hasakura though fretted and worried he
knew that mexico was one thing here in
europe's heart where true power lay his
credentials might be better scrutinized
his lord's bluff could be called
for his clan lord date masamune
was not a king
and hasakura was not really a
representative of the entirety of japan
how would he be received
would they receive him
at all
[Music]
king philip iii holed up in his study
and pondered
the japanese problem
as a six-year-old he had been fascinated
to meet the first japanese embassy in
europe four japanese princes who had
travelled to rome with the jesuits in
1584 and had even embraced them at his
father's bidding
they had been charming pious easy to
communicate with and not at all
threatening
youthful representatives of god's new
children at the very ends of the known
world
[Music]
then the news of christian persecutions
in japan had started tales of great
hardship forced apostasy by torture and
glorious martyrdom
it seemed that the conversion of the
heathens was not going as smoothly as
the young princes and the priests who
accompanied them had claimed
catholic europe reacted with horror
japan had been the great hope of rome a
well of souls to replace the cursed
protestant heretics in northern europe
but japan had turned from missionary
heaven
to missionary hell
and if that wasn't enough those northern
heretics had taken heart at news of
rome's problems in the region and
redoubled their efforts to reach the
fabled lands of riches
a battle for the soul of these new
heathens was coming
phillips sighed and returned to the
problem at hand
a tough-looking official japanese
ambassador in outlandish clothes was
requesting an audience with a formal
armed retinue and making no attempt
whatsoever to speak in a civilized
european tongue to assure him that all
was well
and ask him to send missionaries
and trade
he had a suspicion that trade was by far
the most important of the two and
furthermore
he knew the truth
a disgruntled man called viscaino who
had previously led a semi-official
diplomatic mission to japan from new
spain had written from mexico to divulge
the reality
this proud ambassador did not represent
the great emperor
he was merely the vassal
of a minor prince
hasakura jaded and exhausted saw the way
the wind was blowing but he could no
more inform philip of the truth than
philip would be able to understand it
japan's true so-called great emperor
lived in poverty
far from the beating heart of japanese
power and the clan who did wield power
the tokugawa could not be seen to send
an embassy to a catholic monarch who
officially at least they harbored great
suspicions of and wished to hold at
arm's length instead the tokugawa had
shared ocean-going shipbuilding
technology so that their relatively
minor vassal lord daate could send the
mission on their behalf lord date in his
turn had sent an already disgraced
underling as his envoy hasakura did
represent the mighty shogun through
smoke and mirrors but should anything go
wrong the blame would fall on hasakura
alone and leave his lord's reputation
intact
the tokugawa could deny everything
multiple slights of hand which philip
couldn't or wouldn't
understand
[Music]
eventually the king granted hasakura the
reception of a minor prince's envoy but
try as he might the revelation by the
ambassador that lord daate requested
king philip to sponsor his baptism and
hasakura's own sincere wish for
immediate christening melted the proud
king's heart
and so on february the 17th 1614
hasakura knelt dressed in a pure white
kimono head bowed in submission in the
church of the disgalthus reales
the harmony of the baso continuo rose
around him and enveloped the space
giving glory to god for his mercies and
the miracle of having a pagan japanese
samurai except the holy rights
asakura could not help thinking back to
the last time he had seen someone in a
pure white kimono
the public seppuku of his father
back in japan white was the colour of
death here in christendom it was the
colour of purity and a symbol of the
cleansing of sin
the latter at least was related his
father had purged his misdemeanors
through suicide
it did not do well to dwell on such
things hasakura had been ordered to do
this by lord daate and he obeyed
but the church's angelic music the
elited atmosphere of sanctity the
ghostly flickering of the candles in
their sconces all hinted at the divine
and as the priest intoned the prayer of
exorcism hasakura's heart fluttered and
he felt lightening pass up his spine
perhaps there was something in this
deuce
perhaps this god was indeed the
all-powerful being these barbarians
claimed
the king embraced him followed shortly
by his new godparents he would
henceforth be known as francisco felipe
hasakura
and so philip permitted hasakura to
proceed to rome despite the protests of
his council of advisors
madame de santropay clapped her hands in
pleasure as she sat in her carriage her
face glued to the glass
before her was a magnificent sight the
japanese ambassadorial train was passing
through town having been forced to make
for port due to bad weather on the
mediterranean
san tropez had never seen anything like
it and never would again
crowds surrounded them wherever they
went but they seemed not to notice or
care they continued dignifiedly on their
tour of the town
every now and again one of them would
nonchalantly take a small piece of soft
paper wipe his nose then discard it
the crowds of goping commoners pounced
on each foul disposal of tissue fighting
for the privilege of possessing it
madame did not know which was more
amusing the sight of grown adults
fighting over a snot rag or the fact
that the japanese would use and discard
such an expensive and rare commodity
with so little thought
was paper really so cheap in the orient
when she had visited them in their
temporary residence they had let her
touch a piece of this paper it was so
soft almost like silk
the japanese ate alone in splendid
isolation admitting none to their dining
room save their spanish escorts and the
seven cooks and servants they brought
with them
but madame had heard rumors that they
didn't eat with hands and knives not
even touching the food at all but used
two dainty little sticks held in three
fingers how wonderfully exotic and
clever what would these delightful
orientals think of next
after a few days the weather calmed and
a small corner of france suitably wowed
hasakura and his retinue continued on
their roman journey
accompanied by the pope's cousin
cardinal borgese and ten beautifully
mounted knights the japanese mission
processed piously as pilgrims through
rome's porta angelica to the sound of
fanfares and drums
hasakura was once more granted the high
honor of a personal carriage as the
trumpets continued their curt calls of
salute cannon fire joined in as
kasakura's men progressed through the
streets warping despite themselves at
the magnificent saint peter's basilica
and the five-pointed fortress of castel
sant'angelo rome's citizens lined the
route craning their necks from upper
windows and balconies to see the
wondrous event
the japanese were here
freshly shaved heads shining in the
autumn sun march through the streets
almost like toga-bound dignitaries and
lichter-bearing guards of rome's own
distant past
[Music]
a few days later deep within the
quirinal palace garbed in a white silk
kimono decorated with motifs of birds in
flight and gambling animals hasakura
slowed and solemnly approached the papal
throne
the lord ambassador went down on one
knee bowing his head humbly three times
before kissing the pope's feet as he
offered the lord's letter of greeting
and submission to his holiness
hasakura waited reverently as the latin
version of his letter from date masamune
was read out
[Music]
kissing the holy feet of the great
universal most holy lord of the entire
world pope paul in profound submission
and reverence i date masamune king of
oshu in the empire of japan humbly
declare
the franciscan padre luis sotelo came to
our country to spread the faith of god
on that occasion i learned about this
faith and desired to become a christian
but i still haven't accomplished this
desire due to some small issues
however in order to encourage my
subjects to become christians i wish
that you send missionaries of the
franciscan order i guarantee that you
will be able to build a church and that
your missionaries will be protected i
also wish that you select and send a
bishop as well
further as our country and new spain and
neighboring countries could you
intervene so that we can discuss with
the king of spain for the benefit of
dispatching missionaries across the seas
for all the rest i thoroughly rely on
hasakura and sotelo and shall ratify
anything they may conclude and ratify in
my name
when the reading was finished after a
moment of silence in the thronged
courtroom the pope rose and warmly
welcomed the japanese ambassador who had
traveled so far to his presence
nay he stated hasakura's very arrival
was testament to the power of the
christian faith to bring together lords
and kingdoms from opposite ends of the
earth
hasakura's heavy heart danced a speedy
jig and he felt the weight of all those
thousands of miles of travel lift from
his shoulders
to be welcomed in this way by the pope
himself was to have at least achieved
something on this epic but often lonely
and fruitless seeming voyage
later that night a candle fluttering in
the sconce the venetian ambassador
pondered the words of dartay's letter
for all the rest i thoroughly rely on
hasakura and sotelo and i shall ratify
anything they may conclude and ratify in
my name
this was clearly an appeal to the pope
to supply secret aid
should his holiness be bold enough to
persuade king philip to send troops from
new spain and manila
perhaps spain would find a new colony
and the pope
millions more souls
[Music]
there followed a round of congratulatory
feasts masses present giving and honor
bestowing hasakura became a citizen of
rome gained a new coat of arms and was
portrayed in paintings engravings and
print all over the continent
but he got
little else
nothing that date had asked for
nothing more than effusive but
meaningless words of encouragement
the pope had passed the buck back to
king philip and hasakura could do little
but wait
his fate was out of his hands
even more so than he could understand
for back in his home islands on the
other side of the world another
globe-trotting explorer was playing his
hand
before his visit hasakura had known
little of europe
but he had heard of a place called
england
for on his travels with lord daate he
had by chance met one of the strangest
men in japan
the englishman
called me ura anjin
[Music]
william adams otherwise known as mira
anjin sat with his new english colleague
richard cox in the recently founded
english trading post in western japan
and tried to remember how to speak
english
he had hardly done so since the death of
his brother on the long voyage that had
trapped him in japan that had been 14
years ago
in those years he had first managed to
persuade lord tokugawa he was not a
pirate
then he had learned japanese swiftly
being used as a shipwright gunnery
expert navigational authority and
diplomatic advisor and was swiftly
promoted to high rank he had been given
his japanese name a wife and a thief
with hundreds of farmers and warriors
under his control
not bad for a lad from the small town of
gillingham in southern england
the subject under discussion with
richard cox this evening filled him with
fire
they were discussing the catholic
problem
cox had been sent undercover into japan
by king james's government to undermine
catholicism end spanish and portuguese
trade in the country and to persuade the
japanese to invade the philippines thus
ending spain's rich trade with china it
was a lot to accomplish and there was no
time to lose
as soon as the first official english
trade ship reached japanese shores in
june 1613 four months before hasakura
set sail for north america cox had
sought out adams and filled him in on
the 15 years of english news he had
missed during his long isolation
and now
they plotted
cox asked adams to take every measure
possible to inform those in power in
these distant islands about the
nefarious jesuit and spanish attempts to
assassinate english monarchs back home
and if possible to arrange for cox to
personally speak with certain lords in
the shogun's inner circle
and so the english spent the next few
years feeding the increasingly wild
flames of anti-spanish feeling at the
japanese court with a drip drip drip of
information as fuel
the shogun hidetada and his retired
father ieyasu were especially
unimpressed with the information that
the jesuits believed regicide was an
acceptable tactic
what business did these unwashed foreign
barbarians have effectively claiming
their distant laws applied in japan and
threatening the stability and future of
the newly forged peace
asakura could not know it but everything
he was working for on the other side of
the world was being carefully destroyed
by that strange man he had met briefly
so many years ago and the english
machinations
in japan
[Music]
signs of trouble didn't take long to
appear
despite their roman triumph hasakura and
his men were no longer welcome in spain
that much was made clear by the refusal
of their request to stay in or near
madrid to await king philip's reply to
date masamune's letter they were sent to
seville instead spain's exit gate and
told to await king philip's pleasure
there
while hasakura had been touring europe
king philip had been receiving more and
more reports of the increasing plight of
the catholics in japan the highest
ranking christians were giving up their
faith being forced into exile or
executed and sometimes justified
sometimes trumped up charges
it was a long wait but eventually philip
consented to a letter
it contained little meaningful in it
besides requests to support catholic
propagation but it was a letter
and not unfriendly in tone
a victory of sorts
[Music]
though many of hasakura's men had left
for new spain in 1616 the lord
ambassador himself eventually took ship
with his letter in july 1617
remaining in spain were dozens of
samurai whom hasakura had allowed to
stay
he was not to know it but no new
japanese person would set foot on
european soil
for hundreds of years
[Music]
at the same time as hasakura was sailing
back across the atlantic shogun hidetada
decided to suppress catholicism and
expel the jesuits once and for all
it happened on september the 8th only a
day after englishman richard cox himself
had briefed key shogunal advisors on new
information from europe about spanish
and jesuit involvement in regicide and
interference in sovereign nations
government
cox had been ecstatic
but hidetada had decided to take no
risks
he also confined the english and dutch
to the remote island of gerardo and
closed all the other english trading
posts throughout japan with immediate
effect
this was a death knell to england's
japanese presence
over the coming weeks a desperate cox
has repeatedly refused an audience even
william adams was unable to change the
shogun's mind
asakura remained in mexico city for five
months
while there he was informed of the
catholic disaster by a certain diego
santa who had been expelled from japan
as a result of cock's machinations
significantly all of king philip's gifts
had been returned with the deported
priests it was a strong message of
rejection and dismissal from a superior
to an inferior the message was that
japan would have nothing more to do with
spain and its impertinences
and so the missionaries who had been
earmarked to accompany hasakura to open
their new missions in date masamune's
territory were assigned to new tasks
hasakura
had truly failed
there would clearly be no more
missionaries from catholic countries in
japan
he knew that if hidetada was serious
enough to deport a representative of the
king of spain then lesser priests would
simply be executed
torture crucifixion and burning awaited
them
and so it was with a heavy heart that
hasakura boarded the date maru in
acapulco
he had considered staying in new spain
and had allowed some of his men to do so
they decided to become barbers of all
things
as he watched the waves laugh against
the side of the ship and felt the cool
breeze on his face
he contemplated the debacle
the hasakura name would now be
besmirched twice fold
failure of his mission and the
criminality of christian conversion
he had failed his lord
his ancestors
and his descendants
and so after an extended stay in manila
two years later hasakura at last made
the final short leg of his journey to
nagasaki
and eventually wearily home to the far
northern city of sendai date masamune's
seat
it had taken seven
long years
hasakura genuflected before his lord in
the vast tatami matted chamber
in front of him servants had placed the
gifts from europe new spain and manila
in lacquered boxes covered with silken
cloth
date masamune ordered his vassal to
raise his head so they could talk
his eyes took in the walls covered in
gilt paintings of pine trees tigers and
birds so intricate he felt they might
fly out of the pictures and around the
hall
first date received the gifts among them
a portrait of pope paul v and one of
hasakura himself praying
then the interrogation began it lasted
all day as hasakura told of everything
he had seen and all the events which had
come to pass the pope and king philip's
personal letters to date were submitted
along with translations and received
cautious approval
but when it came to the details of the
breakdown in trade talks the loss of the
ship and the failure to bring
missionaries
date rose up in a fury hasakura knew
that at the back of his lord's mind
despite everything he had harboured
hopes that the mission would bring back
secret messages of support offers of
weapons and the rights to trade over the
ocean to new spain
data's domain could have potentially
become one of the most powerful in japan
yet it was not to be
seven years of travel diplomacy and an
ocean of his lord's silver later
all
for nothing
two days later catholic persecution
commenced in earnest in date's domain
all christians were ordered to abandon
their faith if they did not nobles would
be exiled and common as killed
rewards for the denunciation of hidden
christians were to be generous and
henceforth no propagation whatsoever
would be tolerated
hasakura passed away two years later
while he had not redeemed his family
name he had not been punished further by
his lord
it was the best result that he could
have hoped for in the circumstances
[Music]
cursed the day the barbarians had
brought word of their god to date
masamune's domain
he cursed the day his grandfather had
returned from the other side of the
world and he cursed the fact that his
grandfather had not kept his stories
to himself
despite the interdiction against
catholicism hasakura had propagated to
his family and they had in secret kept
the faith in their hearts long after his
death
several of their servants had been
caught and tortured
hasakura's father
suniori had been denounced
now suninobu watched as his father the
ambassador's son knelt for execution
like a common criminal
his crime was not to have denounced
christians on his estate his wife had
been put to death three years before for
similar crimes
but suni nori was not permitted the
honor of seppuku and the family's title
on land was to be confiscated
the blade came down the head rolled
slowly in the dirt of the execution
ground
and blood weld like an ocean around it
this pool of blood was a symbol of the
defenses that japan now built against
visitors from overseas
no more would ships be free to land
nationwide
like europe they would have designated
ports depending on their place of origin
unlike europe travel and settlement
within japan would be prohibited
and would remain so for more than 200
years
and so
the second japanese embassy to europe
was quietly
forgotten
two centuries of isolation had finally
come to an end
the japanese ambassador iwakura tomomi
in the midst of the grand world tour
which would come to be called the
iwakura embassy covering 120 cities and
12 countries across the globe
stood
in baffled silence
the italian librarian standing before
him with a quiet smile on his face
had done something that despite all the
incredible things he had witnessed on
his tour
truly surprised iwakura
the grinning man had produced two
letters from centuries ago
in latin but clearly signed in japanese
by a certain hasakura
a samurai
who was this man how had he been in
contact with venice 250 years ago the
japanese party conversed excitedly
perhaps a christian refugee seeking aid
against tokugawa persecutions perhaps a
warrior from a defeated faction washed
up on these far shores on returning home
they determined to find out more about
this strange mysterious and forgotten
episode in samurai history
and so back in japan later that year
iwakura spearheaded the rediscovery of
hasakura and his men's globe spanning
adventure artifacts hidden away by the
dartai clan for more than 200 years
resurfaced including the portraits
exotic weapons and catholic artifacts
the emperor meiji himself made a point
of viewing the treasures during his tour
of the northeast in 1876
and hasakura's achievements became part
of the fabric of the less than a
decade-old newly formed empire of japan
an old tale of global voyaging and
diplomacy gave a new nation
international ancestors
and spurred it to a modern future
hasakura would have given thanks to god
for the delivery of his family name from
disgrace and the honor done him by his
future fellow countrymen and emperor
a fitting end
to his amazing tale
it had been worth it
after all
[Music]
you